en 2010 huit et vingt mille le dos a été
brûlée sur près de 45 % de son corps
majoritairement les jambes est la suite
d'une explosion de gallons d'éthanol
utilisé pour un feu de camp j'ai
vraiment passé de mourir là ce moment
alors ça a été éprouvant adam je restais
là 21 jours aux soins intensifs dont
cinq jours dans le coma provoqué il vint
me ledoux contre parmi les 120 grands
brûlés annuellement de l'est du québec à
qui nous propose des vêtements
compressifs comme traitement c'est un
vêtement qui est confectionné dans un
tissu qui est élastique et qui est moulé
sur le corps donc sur la partie qui doit
guérir c'est l'idée c'est de
l'incompréhension égal sur pokémon 1 /
développement des cellules qui essaye de
se réparer qui s'amène l'apparition du
katri ce qu'on appelle hypertrophique
amène une mauvaise mobilité les
vêtements sont confectionnés dans cet
atelier de couture de l'institut de
réadaptation en déficience physique de
québec
quelques 300 vêtements sont créés chaque
année toutes les parties du corps
peuvent être couvertes même le visage en
raison d'une perte d'élasticité avec le
temps les vêtements sont changés tous
les deux à trois mois
on va utiliser l'eau les vêtements
compressifs 23 heures sur 24 dans le
fond étant donné que la peau est active
l'eau en tout temps puis ses vêtements
alors vont être portés par les grands
volets l'or pour une période d'environ
un an donc ses vêtements alors vous
permettent d'améliorer l'apparence des
cicatrices de diminuer les démangeaisons
un récent la peur fruit d'une
collaboration entre les équipes du sud
la capitale nationale et le chu de
québec confirme les bienfaits du
vêtements compressifs le dernier rapport
qui viendraient sortir des manques que
l'offre de service est adéquate le
piquant ni vraiment son veux dire à tous
d'être là travail ce qui se fait dans le
monde qui était intéressant aussi dans
cette évaluation le sait qu'on a sondé
les usagers lui avait trouvé que les
vêtements compressifs été efficace
yvan bilodeau qui a été greffée du
reprise a constaté une nette
amélioration et jean ils sont quand même
bella j'ai repris le travail je pense
dis moi un après shrek a pas trahi à
temps plein mais j'aime mieux travailler
à temps partiel puis prend du bon temps
ici nicole germain radio canada québec